wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
also nico für was interessierst du dich
ich interessiere mich für fußball
interessiert sich für fußball noch einer
sorry ich mag fußball am ende du kannst
nico auch fragen ob er sich noch für
andere dinge interessiert ok
interessierst du dich für literatur
literatur liest du gerne oder hast du
viele bücher zum beispiel romane oder
krimis natürlich ich habe mich schon
immer
ich habe mich schon immer für bücher
interessiert du beschäftigst dich sicher
auch gerne mit politik oder politik ich
warum weil alle politiker so viel liegen
letzte frage selber was kannst du
besonders gut kannst du fahrrad fahren
ich kann nicht fahrrad fahren wirklich
aber das geht nicht wir fahren alle
fahrrad
ich bringe es dir bei ich verspreche dir
hast du morgen zeigt
ok warte selber nico muss erst sagen was
er nicht gut kann ich glaube er kann
nicht gut sehen
du hast gesagt du bringst du uns ein
weihnachtslied ja
[Musik]